>> Laura: WELL, DID YOU SEE THE
FIREWORKS DURING THE QUESTION OF
THE DEPUTY AG?
ROD ROSENSTEIN OVERSEEING THE
HESITATE TO VENT THEIR
FRUSTRATIONS WITH HIS HANDLING
OF THE PROBE.
>> YOU WROTE THE MEMO SAYING
COMEY SHOULD BE FIRED AND SIGNED
THE FISA EXTENSION FOR CARTER
RESCUED MORE SO THAN JEFF
SESSIONS BECAUSE YOU MADE
DECISIONS AFFECTING BOTH PRONGS
OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU DONE THAT?
>> I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WERE IT
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO RECUSE, I
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY.
>> IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE OF
WRONGDOING BY ANY MEMBER OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, PRESENT IT TO
THE DAMN GRAND JURY.
IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY,
WHATEVER YOU GOT.
FINISH THE HELL UP!
THIS COUNTRY IS BEING TORN
APART.
>> THE BEST THING WE CAN DO IS
FINISH IT APPROPRIATELY DOES
REACH A CONCLUSION.
EVIDENCE.
>> DID YOU READ THE FISA
APPLICATION BEFORE YOU SIGNED?
>> I WON'T COMMENT.
>> WHY ARE YOU KEEPING
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS?
>> I AM NOT KEEPING ANY
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS THAT
IS APPROPRIATE.
>> YOU ARE THE BOSS,
MR. ROSENSTEIN.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
MY JOB IT IS TO RESPOND TO YOUR
CONCERNS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERNS.
>> I THINK THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WILL SAY
OTHERWISE.
>> YOU ARE USING THIS TO ATTACK
ACT TINGED.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WON'T GIVE
US WHAT YOU ASKED FOR.
>> THAT IS NOT ACCURATE.
>> IT IS ACCURATE.
WE HAVE CAUGHT YOU HIDING
INFORMATION.
>> Laura: ANYONE ELSE GET
NERVOUS DURING THAT EXCHANGE?
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDEH
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDE
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDY
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDY M
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDY McC
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDY McCAR
JOINING MEAR ANALIS ANDY McCARTY
JORDAN'S QUESTIONING WHEN YOU
FOUND TO BE BADGERING.
I WAS WATCHING AT MY RADIO
STUDIO.
I WINSED.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO INTERRUPT
A WITNESS IT MAKES YOUR CASE NOT
LOOK THAT STRONG.
LET HIM HAVE THE ANSWER.
I THINK HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT NOT
HAVING ENOUGH TIME.
PART OF JORDAN?
>> IT WASN'T A FATAL MISTAKE.
HE WENT TO THE TEDDY KENNEDY
SCHOOL OF CROSS-EXAMINATION.
YOU ASK A HOSTILE QUESTION AND
INTERRUPT THE PERSON YOU ARE
QUESTIONING.
MY OBJECTION IS NOT TO THE
BASHING ROSENSTEIN IS SOMETHING
ANDY SPOKE TO SEVERAL TIMES IN
AGO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THE ABSOLUTE
AUTHORITY TO ORDER ROD
ROSENSTEIN TO TURN OVER
EVERYTHING TO THE CONGRESS.
IF HE DIDN'T, AND ROSENSTEIN
DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT, HE COULD
RESIGN OR IF HE REFUSED, THE
PRESIDENT COULD FIRE HIM.
WHY HASN'T HE DONE THAT?
>> Laura: LET'S ASK ANDY.
WHAT IS THE DELAY?
WHY WON'T THE PRESIDENT SAY
TOROSE ROSE ENOUGH OF THESE
CONTINUING RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE
WE ARE COMPELLING YOU TO RELEASE
THE DOCUMENTS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO RELEASE
THAT WAS CLEAR TODAY.
WHY WON'T THE PRESIDENT DEMAND
THEY BE RELEASED AND GET THIS
SHOW ON THE ROAD?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
THE GREAT IRONY OF THE HEARING
WAS MY FRIEND JIM JORDAN LAYING
INTO ROD ROSENSTEIN SAYING YOU
ARE THE BOSS.
THESE PEOPLE WORK FOR YOU.
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS THAT
ROSENSTEIN WORKS FOR TRUMP.
PRECISELY THE POINT YOU MAKE IS
TRUE.
TRUMP CAN ORDER THIS.
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND IS THAT HE
GOTTEN ADVICE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S PARTICULARLY
GOOD ADVICE.
BECAUSE HAS BEEN UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR OBSTRUCTION
AND BECAUSE THE CRITICS OF TRUMP
CONFLATED IN THE PUBLIC MIND THE
REPUBLICAN PERSUIT OF AGENTS
AND MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION.
IF TRUMP ACT TO FORCE DISCLOSURE
AND HELP CONGRESS HE IS
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
I THINK THAT'S NUTS.
>> Laura: I GET IT.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE
AT.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT.
JOHN, SO MANY THINGS IN THIS
HEARING THAT WERE WILD.
ONE WAS WHEN HE WAS ASKED,
QUESTION ABOUT DID YOU READ THIS
FISA WARRANT?
HE SAID YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HE SAID I HAVE 100,000
EMPLOYEES.
BUT WANTS TO ROOT OUT ANY
CORRUPTION.
HE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T READ THE
WARRANT OR GLANCED OVER SO HE
CAN'T REMEMBER THE SPECIFICS.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS IS MOVING SO
SLOW.
AT THIS POINT, THE DOJ HAS TO
STOP WITH THE GLACIER
PERFORMANCE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO SPEED IT UP AND
GET THE ANSWERS OUT THERE.
>> Laura: AND GOWDY WENT CRAZY
A QUESTION.
BUT TO TAKE HIS TIME TO MAKE
SURE HE GOT QUOTED AND THE SOUND
BITE WAS USED ON MOST EVENING
NEWSCAST.
CABLE AND SOCIAL MEDIA:
GET THIS THING WRAPPED UP.
WHAT IS TAKING SO LONG?
PRESSING ANOTHER MATTER ABOUT
PETER STRZOK.
I WANT TO PLAY THAT AND GET
>> WHY DID YOU TELL PETER STRZOK
NOT TO ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS
YESTERDAY.
I ASKED HIM IF HE EVER
COMMUNICATED WITH GLENN SYMBOLS.
-- SIMPSON.
HE SAID I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
WHY?
>> I DIDN'T GIVE PETER STRZOK
ANY INSTRUCTIONS.
HOW DO I KNOW?
>> THAT WORKS FOR YOU, IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR US.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK
ROSENSTEIN CAME ALL WELL.
HE CAME OFF AS DEFENSIVE AND
MEAN TO ME IN THE MEDIA.
WELCOME TO THE BIG-LEAGUES.
THE DEPUTY AG IS HOT RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE 2
THIS IS THE BIGGEST CASE THE
RUSSIA CASE AND THE HILLARY
EMAIL CASE, THEY DOVE TAIL
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF THIS AGENT.
HE HAD A DUTY TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> I THINK HE DID BETTER THAN
TWO IMPORTANT THINGS.
ROSENSTEIN MADE TWO POINTS.
NUMBER 1, I AM NOT THE ONE AND
NOBODY AT DOJ AS OPPOSEED TO THE
FBI, NOBODY IN ROSENSTEIN'S SHOP
TOLD PETER STRZOK WHAT TO SAY OR
TO DO WITH THE REDACTIONS
INCLUDING THE LATEST OUTRAGEOUS
REDACTION.
WHEN HE WAS TOLD THERE WERE
REDACTIONS HE BROUGHT IN A U.S.
ATTORNEY FROM CHICAGO.
FOR MANY YEARS ON AND OFF, THERE
HAS BEEN A ROGUE ELEMENT IN THE
FBI LEADERSHIP THAT OBSTRUCTS
THESE KINDS OF INVESTIGATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S OUTRAGE.
HA TEXT MESSAGE WAS NOT SENT TO
THE CONGRESS.
THE QUESTION IS:
WHAT WILL BE DONE ABOUT IT?
I THINK THE DOJ SHOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: ANDY, ANY
REPURCUSSIONS FOR WHAT WAS DONE?
I WILL TAKE CARE OF IT, MEANING
INTENT TO  BE A PROBLEM.
TRUMP WON'T BE A PROBLEM.
THAT DOESN'T GO TO THE CONGRESS?
>> OF COURSE.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM I THINK THAT
ROSENSTEIN HAS.
I THINK, FOR EXAMPLE, I WONDERED
HIS ANSWERS WERE SINCIBLE BUT --
SENSIBLE BUT THE SMIRK ON HIS
FACE WAS OFF PUTTING.
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE
YOUR MOUTH IS.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BE CREDIBLE
AND SAY AT THE SAME TIME, WE ARE
GIVING YOU ALL OF THIS
COOPERATION.
WHEN WE FIND SOMEBODY WHO WITH
HOLDS STUFF, WE DON'T DISCIPLINE
THEM.
>> Laura: WHAT I AM LOOKING FOR
FROM OFFICIALS:
MAKE SURE HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T
GET PROSECUTED AND THEY WERE
WHY ISN'T THIS GUY ROSENSTEIN
ANGRY?
HEAD COACHERSHIP POSITIONS.
-- I HELD LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
AND I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
>> Laura: THE BUCK STOPS HERE?
I GUESS NOT.
>> THEY LET STRZOK OUT A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO.
>> YES.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE IS GONE.
HE IS OVER THERE.
>> Laura: BUT HE WAS MOVED TO
HUMAN RESOURCES.
>> WE NEED HUMAN RESOURCES.